then you had boxing as well
I think the the questions were answered
as far as is Earl Spence the same talked
a little bit about it with Luke Thomas
who worked the fight Luke Thomas
actually got choked up talking about he
worked the fight Luke Thomas and Ariel
worked together for the first time and
since they're MMA fighting days one a1b
as far as journalist goes in the sport
yeah they're both so good Luke came on
the show I told him I said one of the
things that need to be answered is is
Earl spent the same after the two car
wrecks the retina surgery on his eye
that was answered he's not the same if
you watch aerial Spence before he wasn't
the same guy bud has gotten better I
felt bad for Errol Spence like I'm
watching he's such a nice guy if you've
ever met early such a good person both
of them are great people you see Earl
Spence's face he has he just has the
friendliest face in the world it's like
bloodied and nothing's working getting
countered left and right he gets knocked
down multiple times he's never been
knocked down before it was just tough to
watch